it's been quite a while since I've done
an unboxing video and in this case
there's no box it's a bag full of stuff
and there's a little funny story behind
this my mother-in-law Shirley sent this
home with my wife because you know as
she knows I go to almost home cat
shelter probably at least once a week
doing volunteer work or sometimes just
spending time with the cats and she knew
sassy you know she was Sassy's cat
grandma and we'd often take sassy to uh
her yard out in Brookfield and let them
explore and have a good time and all
that sort of stuff so she was thinking
about me the other day and she put
together this let's call it a cat care
package of some sort you see the cat on
the front and it's I guess got a lot of
cat really stuff to you know um make
sure that uh I know that there's
somebody thinking of me and my love for
cats and missing sassy and all of that
and since I can't be at almost home
every day maybe these things would
somehow substitute or fill in a gap so
there's a good bit of uh tissue paper
and then things are wrapped up in here
it looks like there's a lot of things so
let's see what all of these are first uh
we have a book no naughty cats the first
complete guide to intelligent cat
training by uh Deborah perotin DVM and
Sherry sub Cohen uh says a program
that's good for you good for your cat
and good for your home so should be
interesting to check out another thing
that I don't know maybe this is another
book
um all I need to know I learned from my
cat by Susie Becker I'm guessing yeah
this is uh an illustrated book so it
tells you what to do for example eat
when you're hungry when you're not
hungry play with your food and it's got
a bunch of cat illustrations so that
should be uh interesting to check as
well looks like there's there's actually
a card I'd better do this
first since that's typically how you go
about these so from the cat high it's
just me oh that's right this is actually
a belated birthday present I I forgot
about that pausing for a moment to wish
you a happy birthday and Basque and your
general wonderfulness joining all the
cats you love and uh have loved to say
you are perfect p u r r Fe C and we love
you rich and Shirley so a cat related
card um let's see what else so here's
something that's that's not in a package
looks like I've got some fruit snacks
you can take those along with me uh as I
teach today that'll be kind of nice
little treat to have during the middle
of the day I think this must be another
book let's see what we got here uh Pet
Rescue Adventures the kitten nobody
wanted by Holly web and looks like it's
a uh children's book with like big uh
lettering and a lot of illustrations so
yeah this will be nice I'll check this
out and
uh I'm sure I can pass that on to
somebody I might actually take this to
to almost home uh and uh you know put it
in the the Shelf there not that the cats
are going to read it but all right uh
let's see we got a what looks to be a
little bit more substantive book here uh
this one looks like perhaps a more
scientific animal behavior behavioral
study cat watching by Desman Morris why
cats purr and everything else you've
wanted to
no um and so this has a whole bunch of
chapters like why does a cat purr why
does a cat like being stroked why does a
cat tear at the fabric of your favorite
chair why does a cat roll over to lie on
its back when it sees you all the way
down
to why do we say it is raining cats and
dogs so yeah this this should be quite
interesting as well looks like that has
quite a few
illustrations
yet another book let's see what this one
is the cats out of the bag truth and
lies about cats by Max
CER uh looks like he's also done every
dog has its day and
so uh this aha so this has got all sorts
of illustrations in it and all sorts of
things about language referring to cats
for example here's a term I didn't know
MGI the word is usually used
affectionately about a cat but
occasionally it carried a vague feeling
the cat being referred to as a fairly
obscure
background
um so you know oh here's here's another
one cat shark I didn't know there was
such a thing um and we go on and there's
all sorts of other things talking about
emotions
Behavior phrases is like grin like a
Cheshire Cat so I'll I'll definitely
have to check that one out there's quite
a few more books in here let's see what
the next one
is why do cats wear pajamas fascinating
facts about our feline friends do cats
wear pajamas um I don't know that that's
the case but this is uh one that's
Illustrated as well and it talks about
oh it's got all sorts of
questions about cats uh for example oh
here's the titular question why do cats
wear pajamas well they don't of course
but cats are the greatest sleepers in
the world of mammals you can almost
think of their pretty coats as a living
set of very luxurious pajamas a healthy
cat sleeps 16 to 18 hours a day about as
much as a newborn human baby so they
remain babies all their their lives um
all right let's see what we have here
this feels like a book as
well this could be useful for quite a
few people uh Steph Bakers how to live
with a neurotic cat and there are quite
a few cats that can be rather
neurotic um wow this is got a lot of
like
illustrations and
suggestions how to train them you know
how to get them to do things we did in
fact uh have a neurotic cat once um back
in Indiana her name was Mew and she was
probably the most intelligent cat I ever
met I've I've done videos about her I'll
put links to that below and she was so
smart but she we you know it was almost
as if she had a guilty conscience all
the time you know about things so yeah
kind of a interesting correlation
between intelligence and Neurosis oh
this is pretty heavy what is this this
is another book about cats and it looks
like sort of a coffee table book called
just cats and um it's actually uh
pre-owned to Julia happy sixth birthday
we hope it's perfect from her parents I
suppose Melissa and Greg or perhaps aunt
and uncle or something like that so all
sorts of pictures of cats country cats
City cats all sorts of things like that
cats and dogs together always nice to
see so that is an interesting one as
well uh what else this is not a
book
this is mushroom
coffee um
so from however this is supposed to be
pronounced Rua
Risa um so we'll we'll check that out uh
what else is we got in the bag I think
these two are supposed to go together
and we have
some
sandals uh everyday wear that's good
because I haven't had any of these for a
while I won't really use them in the
fall and winter and spring but these
will be handy for the summer once it
gets nice and warm here the boy the
thing that they hang on is as heavy as
the slippers now we're getting down to
the bottom of the bag
more Welch's fruit snacks those will go
into my dossier a little bit later today
have a box here of some
sort what is this Whirlpool Corporation
factory certified
Parts I'm not sure what this is but it's
in a
box and so let's see what's in this box
oh more wrapped up stuff all right so
something heavy something hard something
with a handle oh look at that I got a
mug that's nice it says cat lover on it
I think this would be perfect for me pun
intended um yeah that's that's very nice
I can certainly use that and there's one
item left at the bottom of the bag let's
see what it happens to
be
oh good way to end this I got some
biscotti from
nanis uh which is kind of a place out if
I remember right in Brookfield and uh
you know these are going to be very
tasty I love biscotti and uh probably
save these for tomorrow's
breakfast maybe tomorrow and the day
after I probably shouldn't eat three
biscotti um although it can't be
tempting so that is the bottom of the
bag that's everything in this C bag that
was a blad birthday present cat themed
cat related and we'll see what I do with
with this plethora
of cat books I might you know regi them
move them on or perhaps even you know
raffle them uh to help out almost home
cat shelter where I volunteer uh because
they always can use the the funds um you
the bulk of their their funds are
actually spent on um medical care for
the the cats far more than food and
litter and things like that um they're
always in in need so a lot of cool stuff
thanks to to Shirley I hope that uh she
gets a kick out of seeing this video and
uh lot of uh joy to spread I suppose I
could put all these things back in this
this giant bag and uh we'll see if we
can get some coffee to put in my new cat
lover cup so that's it from from uh this
unboxing